un frein ultra
bienvenue dans la salle à manger de
ginette reno
c'est chez elle qu'elle nous présente
son nouvel album intitulé à jamais
[Musique]
à
après 60 ans de carrière elle nous livre
son album le plus personnel
un peu comme un testament musical elle
s'est d'ailleurs les textes de deux
chansons
j'aimais
[Musique]
si mon dernier coup de coeur parce qu'à
cause de mon âge au départ je pense
quand on a 72 ans et plus a garanti
jeudi limpide en tombe alors je suppose
je me dis si jamais je partais au moins
je les fais vraiment comme si je m'en
allais les yeux de me heli aborde entre
autres l'infidélité l'amour de mère pour
ses enfants et des tabous comme cette
chanson nommé la grosse ya même des
débris en ce moment allez on commence à
me traiter d'abord en faire la grosse
kanak
tu as vu à gauche rien à pied au but a
vu une chute au caire cet album est une
thérapie elle veut maintenant laisser
davantage de place à la femme qu'à
l'artiste
[Musique]
à l'issue on promet qu'elle n'arrêtera
jamais de chanter toutes mes amis ça va
et vient et ce qu'ils font
il me dit a été bonne et je n'ai pas dit
ça avant avec jacques tenir bon même ici
à landry dalo radio canada montréal
[Applaudissements]